the Republican presidential candidates
on the Milwaukee stage have one goal in
common winning Wisconsin it's one of the
key Midwestern swing states that
analysts say Republicans will need to
defeat Democrat Joe Biden in 2024. the
contenders also agree on most of the
major issues their anti-abortion
anti-immigration and anti-jo Biden
they're expected to focus on inflation
crime and what Republicans call wokeness
most people associate the word Wellness
with kind of kindness or liberalism or
anti-racism but with the Republican
primary electorate it's a very powerful
issue Republican primary voters are much
more likely than the rest of the
American electorate to say that they
care about these things that they think
there is a culture War being waged by
the left against them
perhaps the staunchest cultural Warrior
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis who has
struggled to show he can break out of
his distant number two position and beat
Donald Trump the candidates so far ahead
in polls that he doesn't plan to show up
but the Floridian has been unwilling to
take on Trump directly I hope that we
will be focused on the future of the
country rather than some of the other
static that's out there right now that
has created an opening for former New
Jersey Governor Chris Christie who
staked out the anti-trump position and
portrays DeSantis As Trump light if he
thinks he's going to get on the stage to
defend Donald Trump on Wednesday night
that he should do Donald Trump a favor
and do our party a favor come back to
Tallahassee endorse Donald Trump to get
the hell out of the race Tim Scott has
been pitching his rags to Rich's life
story as an example for all Americans to
follow
former vice president Mike Pence is
stuck to a traditional Republican
economic pitch Vivek ramaswamy former
Ambassador Nikki Haley former Arkansas
governor ASA Hutchinson and North Dakota
governor Doug burgum will also be
looking for a breakout moment to make a
memorable mark on voters looming over
all this is the elephant not in the room
Donald Trump and his numerous legal woes
do you want your candidate running from
jail do you want your candidate
campaigning and rallies and critical
Battleground States or do you want him
flying back and forth to different
trials any Contender who takes that
position will be gambling on whether
there are enough Republican voters who
agree to make up for Trump's die-hard
base of support John hendron Al Jazeera
Milwaukee
alive